there is a flurry of talk at least about
the possible fraying of three American
citizens held by North Korea President
Trump tweeting overnights as everybody
is aware the past administration has
long been asking for three hostages to
be released from a North Korean labor
camp but to no avail
stay tuned he was referring to Korean
Americans Kim dong-chul a businessman
detained in 2015 and Kim hak song and
Kim sang deuk who are actually seized by
authorities last year and had worked at
a Christian back Pyongyang University
there were reports the prisoners accused
of anti-government activity were on the
move Trump lawyer Rudy Giuliani sped up
the timeline listen to President United
States he's getting ready to negotiate
probably one of our most historic
agreement since the opening to China
we got kim jung-han impressed enough to
be releasing three prisoners today in
fact some work still needs to be done to
gain their release a senior White House
official later told Fox News
underscoring the urgency the tragic tale
of university student otto warmbier
detained by the north in 2016 who died
following his release last year there is
no indication that they've been tortured
to the greed that otto was where he was
brought to within an inch of his life
and then ultimately died back in the
united states all of this following last
week's summit at the DMZ between north
korean leader kim jongwan and south
korean president
moon jae-in and before the plan summit
involving Kim and president Trump the
release of the Americans is seen by
analysts as a confidence builder for
that summit Mike Pompeo now leading
preparations as Secretary of State and
vice president pants cancelling today a
Latin America trip to focus on the
meeting the president feels like
stopping a nuclear war and helping
protect the safety and security of
people across the globe would certainly
be
the number-one priority of the President
of the United States the Trump Kim
summit is expected to happen late this
month or maybe early in June
administration officials are hoping
those American detainees will be home by
that